multiplica 13 y por 25 y cuando
multiplicamos números complejos hay que
acordarnos que básicamente es cómo
multiplicar números reales solo que
ahora tenemos este número especial que
se llama a la unidad imaginaria entonces
para realizar esta operación pues
podemos utilizar o bien la propiedad
distributiva que es mi método favorito o
bien podemos utilizar el método foil que
bueno también da la misma respuesta pero
como que hay que aprenderse más cosas y
es un poco más mecánico de cualquier
forma pues vamos a hacerlo tanto con la
propiedad distributiva como con foil
para ver qué nos queda vale bueno
entonces utilizando la propiedad
distributiva lo que vamos a hacer es
distribuir este 13 y sobre estos 2
humanos entonces nos quedaría 1 menos 3
y no menos 3 y multiplicado por este 2
por 2
13 y 13 y x este 5 y por 5 y simplemente
estoy utilizando la propiedad
distributiva que dice que si tenemos a
por bmc a por demás entonces esto es
igual a de ave más a c aquí a a es un
número acá también sólo que está entre
paréntesis es uno menos tres y ahora
podemos distribuir este sobre éste y
éste sobre éste
por ahora distribuimos por la derecha
entonces que nos quedaría lo voy a poner
en color color naranja 2 x 1 nos quedan
todos nuevo 2 x menos 3 y nos queda
menos 6 y 2 por 13 6 y luego más y aquí
sería 5 y por 15 y mira estoy acá pues
hay que tener un poquito de cuidado
déjame hacer esta operación aparte nos
queda menos tres y menos tres y por
cinco y esto que nos daría pues a ver
menos tres por cinco es igual a menos 15
menos 15 pero
y por iu es igual a cuadrada aquí le
pongo cuadrada sin embargo y cuadrada
por definición es igual a menos 1 así
que tendríamos menos 1 x menos 15 y esto
de aquí es igual a 15 de esta forma
multiplicando estos dos menos 3 y por 5
y nos queda más 15 sale bueno ya que
tenemos las partes reales y las partes
imaginarias tenemos que juntar las osea
juntando las reales con las reales y las
imaginarias con las imaginarias entonces
hay que juntar este 2 con este 15 y
luego este menos 6 y con éste más 5 y
haber el 2 con el 15 que nos queda
2 + 15 es igual a 17 búsqueda 17 en
parte real y luego para la parte
imaginaria es menos seis y más cinco y
si tenemos menos seis de algo y le
sumamos cinco nos queda menos uno de ese
algo o bien sea cinco le restamos seis
nos quedan menos uno y aquí el algo es
la unidad imaginaria y entonces nos
quedaría menos
ok entonces aquí ya tenemos la respuesta
utilizando la propiedad distributiva
déjame resolver otra vez el problema
pero ahora utilizando hoy el método for
efe
i
qué bueno si también nos va a dar la
respuesta y también va a ser correcta y
tiene la ventaja de ser un poco más
rápido pero también es un poco
algorítmico en el sentido de que te
tienes que acordar con de cosas y puede
que en el fondo no entiendas qué estás
haciendo por eso me gusta más la
propiedad distributiva pero de todas
formas vamos a hacerlo es un método que
nos garantiza que hacemos todos los
productos que necesitamos y cómo se hace
pues aquí va efe
aquí va deja de poner los lugares hoy
vale entonces la idea es que f viene de
first en inglés multiplicar los primeros
dos términos es 1 por 2 entonces sería 1
por 2 luego en la y van los de afuera de
los autos 1 por 5 y sería 1 por 5 y
luego va los y los inner o sea los de
adentro que serían este 3 y con este 2
son los de adentro 2 x menos 3 y
entonces le pongo 2 por menos 3 y
finalmente 3
esto poco chiquito pero bueno y
finalmente en la l van los últimos the
last y menos tres y por cinco y entonces
lo voy a poner menos tres sin - menos
tres y por cinco y quedó un poco
chiquito pero espero que se entienda
entonces vamos a hacer los productos a
ver que nos queda uno por 12 21 por 12 2
lo voy a poner con otro color 2 luego
sería 1 por cinco y más 5 y dos por
menos tres y que serían menos seis y
finalmente menos tres y por cinco y que
ya lo habíamos hecho aquí arriba verdad
nos queda a 15 es más 15 ya nada más
sumamos reales con reales e imaginarias
con imaginarias este 2 y este 15 son
reales este 5 y este menos 6 si son
imaginarias
entonces nos queda 2 517 en parte en
parte real más 56 es menos 1 entonces lo
podemos poner mejor como menos
y otra vez es la misma respuesta verdad
17 menos